all right everybody Welcome Back Jenna
Bush Hager and Barbara Bush are still
here hanging out BR new book is called
love comes first in honor of it and also
of some of the greatest love songs out
there it's time for a game we're calling
love comes first or at least at some
point love comes first or at least at
some point at least at some point that's
my favorite part love comes first or at
least at some point let's write that
book I know song uh Jesse is going to
play on Jenna's team she is team Jesse
is a fierce competitor like Jenna but we
are ready for it we are ready okay Lord
I need a little help okay God help
us well hey there Kelly how you doing
girl doing so good you know I'm I'm here
to help now I don't know about helping
you win cuz I hear you're 0 and2 against
Jenna I'm not sure about
power here come on let's go let's go I
can't promise you just pray on it just
pray on it anyway in this game I'm going
to ask a question about a famous song
with the word love in the title now you
be the first to hit your button and
answer correctly to earn a point fields
are allowed so watch yourself and each
team is playing each team is playing for
a mighty prize for their side of the
audience oh
okay okay here we go that feel confident
here's your first question okay in this
song A group of b52s hopped in a
Chrysler yes
it is Love
Shack I'm ah head okay we can do the
next one that was fast glitter on the
mattress glitter on the highway that's
just a weekend in Vegas for okay here's
your next question AR God Michael Bolton
explained what happens when a Man Loves
a Woman No When a Man Loves a Woman yes
they got it
wa now wait you're amazing that could
have been time love and tenderness there
could the love is in there too he got a
Michael Bolton sing a lot of love song
he can sing yeah pipe down Kelly pipe
down it's a tie so it doesn't matter all
right if the phone rings pick it up
because it might be Stevie Wonder
wanting to tell you how much he I just
called to say I love it is I just called
to say I love you we're winning we're
winning we are strong I'm sorry Stevie I
know I'm embarrassed that was an
embarrassment yeah I'm sorry Stevie I I
still prefer those chocolate covers
candy hearts okay here's question number
four okay Dolly wrote it but Whitney
took it to I love unbelievable it is I
Will Always Love You amazing oh my God
are you having a a hard time is this not
working oh it's working time I thought
our wasn't working but they hit it
faster there we go there's there's Kelly
rubbing it in as us yes it is H if you
put another 10cent piece in the jukebox
baby you're going to hear Joan Jet oh
jet jet jet jet hold on hold on hold on
say her name how much time how much time
how much time do you get how much time
that's it Kelly can Ste it is I love
rock and
[Applause]
[Music]
roll
all right well that sound that sound
means we have time for just one more
love song already l no no no no no this
is your this is your big moment this is
your big moment bar you got four points
that's right that's right cuz Jenna and
Jesse you only got one sad little point
there on the board Barbara and Kelly you
got four later again this one is for
5,000 points why not okay okay 5,000
here we go this is your last question in
this song A Promise was made made to
hold you tight baby All Through The
Darkest Hours by those sexy kuners in
Boys to Men I'll Make Love to I'll Make
Love to
You and there it is that
means we out of time barar and Kelly are
the big Winners I just needed your
sister's help just needed your sister
thank you thank you she said no I had to
say congratulations not happy for you
I'm not happy that's why I love you I'm
going to have to come back because I
feel as though I'm going to need a
rematch okay okay that's it we're in the
same building doable doable okay so we
are the winners um but it's my show and
when it comes to the audience everyone
is a winner here so design Marketplace
minted offers personalized holiday cards
with Unique Designs from Independent
Artists to help you spread the love this
season you're all getting a $200 minted
gift card to
welome give it up Jen Bush hag and bar
Bush the new book is called love comes
first it's about
[Music]
[Applause]
now thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home